let's work through another few scenarios
involving displacement velocity and time
or distance rate end time so over here
we have
ben is running at a constant velocity of
three minutes per or three meters per
second to the east 3 meters per second
to the east and just as a review this is
a vector quantity they're giving us the
magnitude and the direction if they just
said 3 meters per second then that would
just be speed so this is the magnitude
magnitude is three meters per second
and it is to the east so they are giving
us the direction so this is a vector
quantity and that's why it's velocity
instead of speed how long will it take
him to travel 720
how long will it take him to travel 720
meters so let's just remind ourselves a
few things and i'll do it both with the
vector version of it and and maybe they
should say how long will it take him to
travel 720 meters to the east
to
to the east to make sure to make it
clear that it is a vector quantity
because so that's displacement as
opposed to just distance but we'll do it
both ways so one way to think about it
if we think about just the scalar
version of it we said already that rate
or speed
is equal to
the distance that you travel over some
time over i might write t there but it's
really a change in time so sometimes
some people would write a little
triangle a delta there which means
change in time but that's implicitly
meant when you just write over time like
that
so rate or speed is equal to distance
divided by time now if you know they're
giving us in this problem they're giving
us the rate if we think about the scalar
part of it they're giving us the rate
they're telling us that that is three
meters per second and they are also
telling us the time
oh sorry they're not telling us the time
they're they're telling us the distance
and they want us to figure out the time
so they tell us the distance is 720
meters
meters and so we just have to figure out
the time so we have so if we just do the
scalar version of it we're not dealing
with velocity and displacement we're
dealing with rate or speed and distance
so we have three
meters per second is equal to
720 meters
720 meters over some change in time
over some change in time and so we can
algebraically manipulate this we can
multiply both sides times time
multiply time right over there and then
we could in if we all if we wanted well
let's just take it one step at a time so
three meters per second
times time
is equal to
720 meters is equal to
720 meters because the times on the
right will cancel out right over there
and that makes sense
at least units wise because time is
going to be in seconds seconds cancel
out with the seconds in the denominator
so you'll just get meters so that just
makes sense there so if you want to
solve for time you can divide both sides
by 3 meters per second so divide both
sides by 3 meters per second
3 meters per second and then the left
side they cancel out on the right hand
side
this is going to be equal to 720
divided by 3
times meters
that's meters in the numerator and you
had meters per second in the denominator
if you bring it out to the numerator you
take the inverse of this so that's
meters let me do the the meters that was
on top let me do that in green let me
color code it so 720 meters and now
you're dividing by meters per second
that's the same thing as multiplying by
the inverse times
seconds per meters and so what you're
going to get here the meters are going
to cancel out and you're going to get
720 divided by 3
seconds so what is that 720 divided by
372 divided by 3 is 24 so this is going
to be 240
this part right over here is going to be
240 and it's going to be 240
seconds
that's the only unit we're left with and
on the left-hand side on the left-hand
side we just had the time so the time is
240 seconds
sometimes you'll see it and just to show
you you know in some physics classes
they'll show you all these formulas but
one thing i really want you to
understand as we go through this this
journey together is that all those
formulas are really just algebraic
manipulations of each other so you
really shouldn't memorize any of them
you should always say hey that's just
manipulating one of those other formulas
that i got before one of those and even
these formulas are hopefully reasonably
common sense and so you can take start
from very common sense things rate is
distance divided by time and then just
manipulate it to get other hopefully
common sense things
so we could have done it here so we
could have multiplied both sides by time
before we even put in the variables and
you would have gotten so if you
multiplied both sides by time here
by time here you would have got on the
right hand on the right hand side
distance is equal to time times rate or
rate times time and this is one of
you'll often see this as kind of the the
formula for rate or the formula for
motion so if we if we flip it around you
get distance is equal to rate times time
so these are all saying the same things
and then if you wanted to solve for time
you could divide both sides by rate
and you get
distance divided by rate is equal to
time and that's exactly what we got
distance divided by rate was equal to
time so if your distance is 720 meters
your rate is 3 meters per second 720
meters divided by 3 meters per second
will also give you a time of 240 seconds
if we wanted to do the exact same thing
but the vector version of it just the
notation will look a little bit
different and we want to keep track of
the actual direction
so we could say we know that
velocity
velocity and it is a vector quantity so
i put a little arrow on top
velocity is the same thing as
displacement
as let me pick a nice color for
displacement blue
as displacement remember we use s4
displacement you you know we don't want
to use d because when you start doing
calculus especially vector calculus well
any type of calculus you use d for the
derivative operator if you don't know
what that is don't worry about it right
now but this right here s is
displacement
displacement at least this is convention
you could kind of use anything but this
is what most people use so if you don't
want to get confused or if you don't
want to be confused when they use s it's
good to practice with it
so it's a displacement per time so it's
displacement divided by time
sometimes once again you'll have
displacement per change in time which is
really a little bit more correct but
i'll just go with the time right here
because this is the convention that you
see at least in most beginning physics
books so once again if we want to solve
for time you can multiply both sides by
time
and you get this cancels out
you get and i'll flip this around well
actually i'll leave it like this so you
get
displacement
is equal to is equal to i can flip these
around velocity
velocity times change in time i should
say or we could just say time just to
keep things simple and if you want to
solve for time you divide both sides by
velocity
you divide both sides by velocity
and then that gives you
time is equal to displacement divided by
velocity and so we can apply that to
this right over here our displacement is
720 meters to the east
so in this case
our time is equal to 720 meters to the
east
720 meters
east is our displacement and we want to
divide that by the given velocity well
they give us the velocity of 3 meters
per second to the east
3 meters per second to the east and once
again 720 divided by 3 will give you 240
will give you 240 and then you have
when you take meters in the numerator
and you divide by meters per second the
denominator that's the same thing as
multiplying by seconds per meter those
cancel out and you're just left with
seconds here
one note i want to give you in the last
few problems i've been making vector
quantities by saying to the east or
going north and what you're going to see
as we go into more complex problems and
this is what you might see in typical
physics classes or typical books is that
you define a convention that maybe
you'll say the positive direction
especially when we're just dealing with
when we're just dealing with one
dimension whether you can either go
forward or backwards or
or left or right we'll talk about other
vector quantities when we can move in
two or three dimensions but they might
take some some convention like positive
means you are moving to
maybe you're moving to the east and
maybe negative means you're moving to
the west and so that way it'll it'll
make well in the future we'll see it'll
make the math a little bit the math will
produce the results that we see a little
bit better so if this would just be a
positive 720 meters this would be a
positive three meters per second and
that implicitly tells us that that's the
east if it was negative it would then be
to the west something to think about
we're going to start exploring that a
little bit more in future videos and we
might have maybe we might say positive
is up negative is down or who knows
there's different ways to define it when
you're dealing in one direct one
dimension